c'est une victoire historique qui est
d'abord et avant tout permis par la
mobilisation de citoyennes et citoyens
d'associations de collectifs et la
France si nous votons bien le texte tout
à l'heure puisque grâce à cela nous
avons fait tomber l'ensemble des
amendements d'obstruction la France
serait alors le premier pays au monde a
inscrire le droit à l'avortement dans sa
constitution cette mobilisation elle est
là vous pouvez la voir alors dans une
partie
des 160 000 signataires d'une pétition
qui ont demandé à ce que soit inscrits
le droit à l'interruption volontaire de
grossesse dans la Constitution et je
crois que l'Assemblée nationale va
envoyer un signal extrêmement fort à
l'ensemble du pays mais aussi à
l'ensemble du monde en votant cette
proposition de loi constitutionnelle